dans le cadre de la préparation de notre
rapport sur l'adaptation des modes
d'action de l'État dans les autres mèes
nous allons nous pencher sur le volet
justice dans les autr mères en
auditionnant ce matin maître Patrick
lingibé membre du Conseil National des
Barreaux ancien viceprésident et
président de la délégation outremaire de
la Conférence des Bâtonniers de France
nous vous remercions maître d'avoir
accepté de répondre à nos question en
présentielle à l'occasion de votre
passage à Paris nos rapporteurs Philippe
B ici présent et Victorin Lurel ont en
effet beaucoup d'interrogations sur le
fonctionnement de l'équipe France dans
nos territoires pour reprendre une
expression du général Laverne commandant
de la gendarmerie d'outrem que nous
avons entendu le 25 janvier dernier ce
fut de la vie de tous une audition très
riche qui a amené à creuser davantage ce
volet essentiel des fonctions de l'État
vous n'avez pas hésité en 2023 à
affirmer que si la justice est en grande
difficulté dans l'exagone
elle est parfois dans un état de coma
avancé outreem en pointant une profonde
crise de confiance sociale envers
celle-ci selon vous les services
judiciaires sont en raison de leur
mission régalienne particulièrement
exposés aux tensions sociales et à
l'insécurité chronique qui traverse
certains territoires ultramarins dans
une série d'articles que nous avons mis
sur des Mées pour les membres de la
délégation vous affirmez aussi que la
problématique carcérale ultramarine ne
résulte pas tant dans son taux de
suroccupation que dans les conditions de
détention qui sont particulièrement
indigne et inhumaine vous y abordez
aussi la question de l'attractivité des
postes dans certains départements d're
maire si les avantages financiers
octroyés au magistrats et fonctionnaires
peuvent parfois y participer ils ne sont
pas suffisants les difficultés de
logement notamment rencontrées par les
nouveaux arrivants sont identifiés comme
un frein aux candidatures par ailleurs
comment fonctionne l'articulation
policejustice qui nous paraît
essentielle et surtout comment
l'améliorer voici quelques questions sur
lesquelles nous souhaiterions vous
entendre après votre exposé liminaire
nos rapporteurs Philippe bah et Victorin
Lurel vous interrogeront sur des aspects
plus précis puis nos autres collègues
poseront leurs questions à leur tour si
elles le souhaite vous avez la parole
cher Maître
oui merci
madame la Présidente merci de
buditionner c'est vrai que la question
de justice euh pas que mais en fait ne
sont pas étrangères euh pour l'outrem
euh
alors
une
unepr je pense que l'outreem est un défi
pour la République
euh parce que il
renvoie pas une une réponse unique mais
pluriel toute la
complexité on a nous avons 13
territoires et
euh 1è statuts différents 13
problématiques différentes
d'ailleurs qui renvoie effectivement à
des interrogations et à des réponses
alors je suis un avant tout un
pragmatique
euh ma
boussole reste effectivement le
bénéficiaire final de toute réflexion et
de toute réponse apporttere c'est qui le
bénéficiaire final c'est le sujet droit
c'est la citoyenne c'est le citoyen qui
se trouve donc chacun des territoires
euh ça veut dire très clairement que le
citoyen ne se préoccupe pas qui fait
quoi l'état une collectivité
territoriale ce qu'il souhaite avoir une
réponse aux
problématiques alors
d'abord premier élément euh je je pense
qu' qu'il faut mettre en perspective euh
s'agissant euh euh des des compétences
régaliennes puisque j' reviendrai aussi
à aborder la question statutaire
pourquoi parce que elle a un lien direct
et j'expliquerai pourquoi avec les
compétences régaliennes et et et et ce
ce qu'on appelle souvent évolution
institutionnelle je dirais en fait c'est
plutôt une amélioration institutionnelle
c'est-à-dire calibrer en l'occurrence
les statutes au regard des bassins de
vie et des problématiques des réponses
qu'elles amènent face aux problématiques
posées euh l'outromè c'est
quoi avant tout et là
euh je crois qu'il faut pas avoir de
langue de bois il faut pas avoir aussi
parce que trop souvent pour l'outreem on
n' pas voulu mettre les mots sur des
problématiques ou parler de
problématiques
par pour éviter de froisser l'outromè
elle est caractérisée et ça c'est une
c'est c'est un marqueur d'ailleurs qui
joue d'ailleurs sur la perception
qu'a chacune des populations
ultramarines au regard des collectivités
territoriale mais de
l'État premier élément vous avez une
très large
euh
pauvreté
euh je rappelle d'ailleurs que on il y
avait une étude qui avait été menée par
la commission nationale consultatif des
droits de l'homme c'était le 26
septembre 2017 euh qui donnait alors
uniquement pour les les CIN dromes le
taux de pauvreté suivant euh en 2017 le
taux de pauvreté de l'Hexagone était é
de
13,20 et il était de 84,5 % à Mayotte et
je vous rappelle à cette période puisque
ce n'est qu'en 2020 que
l'INC
va établir en fait une un taux de
pauvreté qui est
effectivement en référence avec le taux
hexagonal ce qui se passait avant il
était recontextualisé c'estàd Mayotte
84,5 % était recontextualisé à 32,4
%. 61,2 % Guyane recontextualisé à 30,2
% 51,2 % à la Réunion recontextualisé à
%. 49,1 % Guadeloupe recontextualisé à
20,10 % et la Martinie 48,6 %
recontextualisé à 20,6 %. ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'avant 2 20 vous aviez un
miroir en fait indicatif qui était
déformé en
recontextualisant
rualisait le taux de pauvreté alors que
finalement il était artificiel je vous
prends l'exemple de Mayotte 32,4% ça ne
retraduit pas la réalité
maoraise et à cela vous avez un autre
indicateur qui vient téllescoper cela
c'est sur le coût de la vie c'est-à-dire
qu'andoutre m pour effectivement faire
en
résumé on est plus pauvre et la vie est
plus cherre si ça lu faut pourquoi je
vous dis ça parce que euh qu'on va
parler de droit tout à l'heure euh ça
renvoie inévitablement et la dernière
étude de l'INC montre que justement en
outreemè vous avez en fait des atteintes
à des droits fondamentaux enfin
notamment des droits primaires
c'estàdire que les gens ont des
problèmes alors on sait que dans
l'Hexagone mais c'est encore plus plus
accentué en des problèmes effectivement
pour se nourrir en l'occurrence pour
accéder
et donc ça veut dire que la
préoccupation première des
populations c'est leur besoins
primaires c'est c'est effectivement
comment comment bien vivre et mieux
alors que la vie est plus chère et que
les gens sont plus
pauvres sur deuxè
élément télescope parce que vous avez en
arrière-plan effectivement cette
pauvreté avec effectivement un curseur
qui qui est sur effectivement le coût de
la vie qui plus
cher l'état de la justice la
défiance il faut savoir
que du 12 au 28 mai 2021 le cabinet
odoxa
spécialisé
dans a été mandaté par le Conseil
national des
barreaux pour faire en fait une
évaluation de la conception qu'avait les
justiciable de la justice alors
nouveauté c'est que ce paramètre qui
était jusqu'à à l'Hexagone a été je
pense grâce à mes travaux étendus à
l'outreem donc on a en fait une image
de du justiciable en fait de la
population euh donc euh ultramarine même
territoire par territoire de la
conception qu'elle a de la justice et je
vais vous donner les chiffres qui sont
éloquents il ressort de cette étude que
70 % des Français ont le sentiment que
la liberté les droits fond moto ont
tendance à reculer ce sentiment est
encore plus aggravé en d'reemère
puisqu'il atteint 84
% plus d'un Français sur TR affirme que
là où il habite il est difficile de
d'accéder au tribunaux 35 % et qu'il est
difficile de faire valoir ses droits 37
%. 58 % vous tenz ce chiffre des
ultramarins affirment qu'il est
difficile de faire valoir leurs
droit je vous rappelle que devant votre
délégation le 21 novembre
2019 l'ancien défenseur des droits
Jacques
Toubon disait ceci on a le sentiment que
à beaucoup d'égards les habitants des
départements et territoires d'outremer
non'ont pas le même accès au droit ils
ont un accès au droit inférieur à à ceux
qui existent en
métropole cette conatation faite a été
appuyé par des travaux que j'ai mené
moi-même effectivement qui montrait en
en fait une un accès
difficile droit alors je vous signale
justement sur ce point que il y a un
conseil national de l'aide juridique
euh qui euh donc conseille le
gouvernement sur toute la politique
d'accès au droit et qui notamment est
consulté
sur donc les projets de loi sur l'aide
juridictionnelle et de décret et que
pour la première fois le Conseil
national de l'aide juridique a été a un
membre au ma personne un ultramarin qui
a été nommé je nai justement conscient
de ces problèmes j'ai fait créer à
l'unanimité un groupe gr de l'accès au
droit en outreem pour régler les
problématiques territoire par territoire
que je préside d'ailleurs et qui va
auditionner chacun des acteurs je
voulais vous le signaler parce que c'est
une problématique
prignante 3è
élément l'outreem connaî et on le voit
avec
maot des cris ét majeur qui son
cycliqu c'est CR mettre quoi en exerg
pas des compétences
locales ce sont des compétences
régaliennes elle
met donc en exergle en fait des
défaillances dont en fait l'exercice de
compét soit l'immigration police la
justicei
la confiance je pense que l'institution
judiciaire est un passion régalien c'est
même si elle échouait dans les
territoires d'autrem la République à mon
sens tomberait il a par là qui la
nécessité effectivement d'être prise
prise en
compte vous savez qu'il y a eu un
rapport sur les états générau par un
comité donc présidé par jean-mar
sauv euh les sur les 250 pages de pages
et demi sont réservé à l'outreem sans
solution ce sont des diagnosties qui
sont particulièrement
inquiétants parce que je le répète que
si la justice est mal en point dans
l'xagone mais alors là il est est sous
l'eau en d're mer euh j'avais moi parce
que je je voyais
arriver cet aspect que l'outremè
n'aurait pas été traité dans les débats
ça n'a pas manqué
et lors effectivement du lancement des
stats généraux à Poitier où j'y étais je
n'ai pas manqué d'interpeller le
président de la République une
personnable là-dessus qui m'a écrit
d'ailleurs qui me disit oui
effectivement je prends en compte et je
donne des instructions garde des saut il
y a pas de suite he ce qui fait qu'en
fait finalement il y a dans le rapport
vous parcourrez les 250 pages rien sur R
ça veut dire qu'on reste effectivement
questionnement alors que l'outremur a
besoin effectivement de renvois de
signaux importants incarnant la
République la République en fait elle il
faut la conquérir dire que la confiance
ne se décrète pas elle s'acquir et vous
avez vu effectivement le le chif que
vous a donné le cabinet odoxa et et on
voit très bien
qu'effectivement pour les
populations la justice bon il n'ont pas
confiance hein ils considèrent que bon
c'est c'est une justice qui est qui est
partiale alors je vous dis c'est c'est
pas ce que je pense mais c'est faut bien
comprendre
effectivement l'intérêt en l'occurrence
de pour moi un système juridique le
droit d' de pertinence et de performance
que si il répond effectivement aux
problématiques sociétales au corps
sociétal auquel il t à s'appliquer et
surtout de lui inspirer confiance c'est
ça si il n'arrive pas à cet état on
échoue mais qu'on échoue on échoue
collectivement avec la République en MO
puisque effectivement ça ça donne
naissance à d'autres choses vous savez
comme moi effectivement les gens qui
pensent que le droit n'est plus
régulateur et que c'est autre chose moi
je suis un un partis en farouche
effectivement défense du droit je pense
qu'effectivement c'est un système
ordonné qui doit inspirer confiance le
problème c'est que vous avez en fait une
tension entre finalement un outil
juridique et la réponse qu'elle amène
qui qui n'est pas appropriée
et autre élément qui est pour moi
inquiétant
c'est l'isibilité qu'on a abouti de
l'outrem au
[Musique]
sein du je dirais du concert
gouvernemental je m'explique parce que
c'est des choses qui m'est revenu vous
avez compris que comme effectivement je
je suis comme auteur je publié
énormément donc j'ai des retours les
gens me parlent et puis dans les
déplacements effectivement j'ai j'ai
l'occasion de discuter avec les
personnes c'est quoi euh bon vous le
savez comme moi qu'il a un ministère des
outr mè euh et l'une des fonctions
importantes du ministère d'remè
effectivement c'est un rôle de
coordination de l'action gouvernementale
nremè d'assurer une cohérence et une
lisibilité or le problème force c'est de
constater que bon cette lisibilité a
disparu
euh d'autant l'une des critiques
majeures qui est faites c'est
effectivement le fait que le le
ministère des omèes n'est plus un
ministère de ple exercice c'est
ministère qui est placé sous la tutelle
d'un autre ministère bon peu importe
mais sauf que le message qui est renvoyé
c'est effectivement euh vous savez comme
moi que le ministère de l'outreber c'est
un min le ministère de l'intérieur c'est
un ministère qui est caractérisé par
l'ordre public si effectivement la
perception de l'utre maè c'est sous le
prisme de l'ORD publicque c'est que nous
avons échoué he c'est pas la réponse l'
public est une chose mais on peut pas
limiter l'outre mire à l'ordre public
c'est le message euh je dirais
tacitement qui a renvoyé que les gens
reçoivent c'est qu'il considèrent que
bon bah ils nont pas de ministère
vraiment de ple exercice pour faire
valoir les réalités ultramarin et Dieu
elles sont
nombreuses et donc s'il faut passer par
un prise fare ministère dont la
préoccupation première est quand même le
maintien de l'ordre ça je dirais que
c'est un mauvais signal à mon sens
envoyé au population
d'outreè la l'autre aussi euh c'est que
il faut que qu'on comprenne moi qui ai
beaucoup écrit et commenté les décisions
rendu par la judicction administrative
particulement au Conseil d'État en
matière en période de crise sanitaire
euh la crise sanitaire covid a peu
importe les justifications
a créer en fait au sein des populations
inframarines font ce qui revient
le fait de se dire est-ce qu'ils étaient
réellement
effectivement dans un ensemble quelle
est leur place dans la République je
vous rappelle que le dispositif m en
place tous les territoires ultramarins
les populations enfin les personnes qui
se déplaçaient étaient soumis à des
motifs
impérieux je vous rappelle aussi dans le
même temps que le Conseil d'État rendait
un arrêt que j'ai je parle que j'ai
commenté
où effectivement dans le décret était
prévu que les
[Applaudissements]
les Français à l'étranger était soumis à
la démonstration de motif impérieux et
le Conseil d'État effectivement référé
avait effectivement suspensu cette
procédure en disant qu'on ne pouvait pas
effectivement imposer à un français
laificatif de revenir sur son territoire
son pays je veux dire que quel que soit
les fondements en fait ça a créé une
confusion et une idée qui effec
effectivement les les ultramarins
n'étaient pas traité de la même manière
que effectivement les les les les les
Français de
l'xagone alors sur la justice
particulièrement puisque effectivement
j'avais fait des
propositions qui je pense
intéresseront
euh il y avait dans mon article j'ai
publié à la ré du rapport souet 18
propositions alors je vais pas les citer
toutes mais
euh comment se passe aujourd'hui
euh l'affectation
euh de magistrat de greffier parce qu'on
oublie souvent la greffier euh au niveau
effectivement de la justice
euh alors vous avez des territoires qui
sont plus difficiles que d'autres
Mayotte laagienne c'est deux territoires
qui reviennent qui sont considérés comme
très difficiles par rapport à la
Réunion
euh je pense que il y a une
problématique de fond euh au à la
Chancellerie vous n'aveez pas de
direction de
l'outremère ça veut dire que l'approche
en fait de l'outrem qui doit se
singulariser par les
produitmatiques auquel effectivement euh
euh
elle
renvoie l'affectation traité de la même
manière que effectivement une
affectation dans une province c'estàd je
pas vous affectez un
magistrat à Poitier ou en corise ben
c'est la même matière vous affectez
effectivement un magistrat alors il y a
bien un stage de sensibilisation le
National de la magistrature sauf
qu'effectivement vous il faut bien
comprendre que effectivement le le le
magistrat qui arrive dans un dans un
outreom il il est confronté à à une
culture en fait différente à des
problématiques différent différentes euh
et il y a pas réellement alors même si
ça s'est amélioré au niveau de la
campagnement mais il y a pas de
réflexion réelle porté sur chaque
territoire je vous prends des exemple on
va prendre l'exemple de
Mayotte vous savez que Mayot a changé de
mais en changeant de statut on a
supprimé effectivement une juridiction
d'appel qui existe à
Mayot ça veut dire que le justiciable
maoret doit se rendre effectivement à
Saint-Denis de la Réunion pour
effectivement un contentieux lié
notamment chambre d'instruction au
niveau de la
Réunion ça veut dire qu'en fait
finalement on a diminué les droits des
justiciables maoraais don dans une
optique effectivement de réorganisation
administrative autre exemple
parlant vous savez que la giane est
confronté à un problème de trafic de
stupéfant il y a pas que ce
territoire
la le traitement en fait des des
problèmes de de stupéfiant de de grand
trafic est traité
figurez-vous à 1800 km c'est-à-dire en
Martinique qui effectivement concentre
la juridiction inter régionale
euh problématique c'est que euh quand
vous avez des
problèmes
amazonien
sud-américain vous ne pouvez pas avoir
un
prisme qui est déconnecté de la réalité
et moi l'une des propositions que
j'avais faite en fait
c'était d'adapter le droit aux réalités
c'est-à-dire que il faut s'affranchir
aussi quand je vous disais le
bénéficiaire final ce qui est
intéressant c'est c'est le c'est le
justiciable c'est le citoyen il faut lui
apporter une réponse c'est on doit
quitter la doctrine y compris en de
remettre en cause pour apporter des
solutions simples à des problèmes
effectivement quotidiens qui polluent et
qui effectivement permettent la défiance
pour reconquérir il faut des des des des
des réponses adaptées y compris donc
c'était effectivement créer des
juridictions qui soi calibré en
l'occurrence même si je sais que lesg
font partie d'une loi moi j'ai suis VI
discuter avec la Chancellerie qui me dit
oui mais ce sont des mais je ve dire que
il faut savoir ce que l'on veut si on si
on l'objectif c'est bien d'apporter des
réponses concrètes à des situations qui
sont
inédites si nous ne quittons pas on a on
a confondu je pense très sincèrement et
on confond souvent d're ma le principe
d'égal
est celui
d'uniformité vous ne pouvez pas
appliquer un principe
d'égalité sur des territoires qui ne
sont pas
uniformes sinon vous allez à
l'échec et je reviens à la règle de
droit la règle de droit est une réponse
effectivement au corps sociétal auquel
il
s'applique dernier point je voulais
rebondir sur effectivement la question
euh effectivement euh statutaire puisque
effectivement
euh puisque je j'ai eu l'occasion d'être
auditionné par l'Assemblée nationale et
j'ai écrit sur la question
euh moi je je m'inscris plutôt dans une
aujourd'hui c'est vous avez
effectivement une
euh
dichotomie de facette effectivement du
principe d'identité législative et de
l'autre côté de spécialités législativ
pour moi c'est ça relève plus de
l'artifice juridique parce que la
réalité il faut bien qu'en fait on on se
rend compte et on se rend compte qu'on
est dans la justice c'est que sur chaque
bassin de des département région
d'outremer vous vous rendez compte de
quoi vous trouvez dans des bassins qui
sont radicalement différents de
l'environnement que vous avez
dont agonch européen c'estàd que la
norme notre norme est confrontée sans
cesse à une réalité qui est poussé
impulsé par des un nonvironnement qui ne
n'ont pas les mêmes références juridique
que nous et là où j'en viens moi je suis
pour effectivement une fusion d'articles
avec effectivement un principe qui
consacrerait ce que ce que je défondais
en Trine différenciation moi j'appelle
ça de droit différencié parce que je
pense que notre mè est différent même
si dans sa réalité avec des lois
organiques alors pourquoi les lois
organiqu et jeand je voulais faire la
boucle làdessus parce que je pense au
niveau du loi organique il est plus
intéressant de mettre en place des
outils dérogatoire en matière
régalienne toute la réflexion de
votre délégation
pourquoi je vous prends l'exemple de la
Guyane aujourd'hui quels sont les
instruments qui permettent d'assurer la
souveraineté le réaliè envoie la
souveraineté un pays qui n'est pas
souverain dont ces territoirees est un
pays qui pose
problème vous avez des enjeux qui pour
moi effectivement
relèvent qui dépassent d'un département
qui met en défi l'état sa souveraineté
et vous devez avoir des outils qui
permettent effectivement
d'adapter problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui
dans le droit coma très difficile de
faire des dérogations très poussé
làdessus même si elles sont anné que ce
soit pour le trafic de stupéf que ce
soit pour effectivement en matière
d'immigration que ce soit dans d'autres
domaines de la
nationalité je pense qu'effectivement il
faut des réponses et les réponses il
faut il faut sortir des traditionnel à
mon sens pour apporter pour répondre
effectivement problématique de du
justiciable nous de rapporteur donc on
va commencer par Philippe Bas puis
Victorin
lural merci madame la Présidente et et
merci Monsieur le Bâtonnier de votre
exposé nous en sommes au début de nos de
nos réflexions et celleci s'insccrive
dans une
perspective qui pour l'instant est
encore un peu
intuitive il y a quand même
l'idée qui est vérifiée qui est un fait
en
réalité que nous
avons dans une partie au moins de nos
collectivité
ultramarine des problèmes de
sécurité pour leurs
habitants qui
euh dépasse en
proportion tout ce que l'on peut
connaître dans
l'Hexagone et donc il y a sans doute
doute la tentation euh de
euh vouloir mettre en
œuvre un dispositif
répressif que l'avocat que vous êtes ne
peut
euh voir venir qu'avec une part de
méfiance mais enfin l'avocat que vous
êtes aussi est l'avocat des victimes et
donc il a le souci euh de de la sécurité
de la vie société
mais on se demande au début de cette
réflexion si
euh
l'application
euh pure et simple de notre code de
procédure pénale
outremère même si vous relevez dans vos
réponses qu'il y a déjà des
adaptations
euh répond à l'ATT
des sociétés
ultramarines vous êtes à
Cayenne vous connaissez donc
particulièrement bien la situation de la
Guyane que plusieurs de nos collègues
connaissent également très
bien et il est certain qu'il y a une
très vive inquiétude parmi les habitants
de guyan sur la la dégradation très
forte de la situation
sécuritaire et ce qui nous intéresserait
c'est si c'est possible de votre part
maintenant ou plus
tard que vous puissiez nous dire à la
lumière de votre
expérience en quoi
l'application du code de procédure
pénale même avec un certain nombre
d'aménagement déjà
existant ne remplit
pas le contrat de sécurité
que nous
voudrions avoir avec nos compatriotes
ultraarin qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
concrètement faire il a bien sûr la
question des moyens
humains nous ne voulons pas l'ignorer
mais qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
faire pour améliorer la lutte contre
l'orpaillage l'insécurité liée à une
immigration qui viennent d'Haïti
du syinam ou ou du Brésil euh pour
euh rassurer nos compatriotes euh je
parle de la Guyane parce que vous êtes
guyanais mais je sais bien que vous avez
étendu votre champ de réflexion à
l'ensemble de de l'outreem et ça nous
intéresse que vous débordiez évidemment
du champ strict de cette
collectivité alors
votre question renvoie à mon sens
à une autre parce qu'il faut mettre euh
les mots euh son détours sur les
problmiques qu'on a
euh la Guyane comme Mayotte je pense
pose un problème de
fond qui dépasse le cadre judiciaire qui
un problème de
souveraineté
euh que ce soit leur paillège euh
illégal
euh quand vous avez
[Musique]
euh pas des
individus mais
euh toute une groupe en l'occurrence
parce qu'il faut bien comprendre que
euh les la lutte qu'est-ce qu'on
constate en l'occurrence c'est que vous
avez parfois tout un groupe donc de
personnes dans l'UR qui dépasse c'estàd
que judiciairement il faut trèsêtre très
clair on est incapable aujourd'hui
d'apporter une réponse parce que ça
vudrait dire qu'en l'occurrence si on
met on rentre dans le J actuel il
faudrait puisque ce sont des infractions
il faudrait juger les personnes en fait
qui
dépassent capacité
judiciaire les mettre en détention
l'établissement ne suffirait pas je veux
dire par là que pour moi les
problématiques renvoient plus sur des
problématiques non pas de de
modification parce qu'on aura beau
modifier le code de procédure pénale
étendre effectivement les les champ oui
sauf que vous n'aurez vous aurez une
limite effectivement qui est matérielle
c'est que la la juridiction ne pourra
pas juger autant de personnes et la
réponse pénale sera inadaptée parce que
jamais aucun établissement pénitentiaire
ne pourra absorber le nombre de
condamnation non mais c'est une réalité
on n'en parle pas mais j'en parle je
vous le dis c'est la réalité c'est clair
on a beau vous dire renforcer renforcer
moi je vous le dis très clairement son
son détour très sincèrement c'est une
réponse qui VI à l'échec parce que
jamais effectivement l'institution
judiciaire n'aura cette capacité et
quant au à l'administration P elle ne
suivra pas elle pourra pas suivre à moi
d'étendre vous aurez beau étendre
effectivement le nombre de pris an
d'ailleurs vous savez très bien que ça
prendra du temps ne seraitce
effectivement pour lancer les marchés
mais vous n'aurez pas pour moi la
réponse ne peut-être effectivement que
de l'ordre effectivement la coopération
interrégionale avec la fermeté
effectivement de la position française
je dire par là que bon que ce soit à
Mayotte ou que ce soit effectivement
dans l'environnement sur américain je je
vois pas très sincèrement vous savez
euh que pour la Guyane la Guyane est
entourée par par deux pays dans un pays
qui est quand même considéré comme un
pays narcotrafiquant ça veut dire que
vous non on a une problématique de fond
il faut pas non plus faire comme si on
ne voit pas c'est c'est une
problématique géopolitique
géostratégique c'estàdire quelle est la
position que elle dépasse en fait
finalement le système juridique elle
dépasse la réponse judiciaire pour avoir
une réponse politique internationale bon
voilà si si c'est clair si si en fait
vous me demander mon avis modifier le
code de procédure pénale je pense qu'il
y a des adaptations à faire pour doter à
mon sens effectivement les les acteurs
de l'État je pense au procureur de la
République je pense au préfet de de
moyens supplémentaires d'outils
juridiques mais pour moi ça ne suffira
jamais à apporter la réponse c'est très
clair ces réponses seront marginal si
nous ne traitons pas le problème à la
dimension sud-américaine ou pour maotte
pour le connaître parce que je me suis
déplacé et je me suis intéressé à la
question maouress comme toutes les
questions ultramarines vous imaginez on
na pas de réponse s l'occurrence en
droit interne c'est il faut il faut faut
imaginer un instant que c'est pas vrai
c'est c'estche c'est c'est pas nous sur
notre droit on va dire on va en
fait durcir le code de procédure pénal
et puis ça sera résolu c'est pas vrai
c'est faux c'est au contraire je pense
en faisant ça on va envoyer un message
en disant on durcit donc le citoyens il
vont dire bon d'accord l'État et puis en
fait en conclusion on pourra pas
apporter de réponse voilà oui je
j'apprécie la franchise et le réalisme
de de votre réponse qui d'ailleurs n'est
pas complètement fermé sur le sujet des
moyens de moyen juridique de la
répression et ni d'ailleurs sur le sujet
de l'adaptation de l'appareil
carcéral mais qui souligne à quel point
le sujet est maintenant un sujet que
vous qualifiez de souveraineté oui et
est-ce que vous pouvez mettre un peu les
points sur les i et traduire ce que
signifierait pour vous une action de
souveraineté qui nous permettrait face à
un état
narcotrafiquant face à un autre
État
dont les moyens
d'action sont assez différents des
nôtres
[Musique]
euh qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'est-ce
que vous mettez derrière action de
souveraineté est-ce que c'est une action
diplomatique
militaire est-ce que il s'agirait de
rendre
endre étanche les frontières que
constituent le Maroni ou l'oyapo est-ce
que c'est réaliste ça aussi parce que
euh on dit qu'il n'est pas réaliste
d'apporter une réponse par les moyens
juridique et je suis prêt à l'entendre
mais est-ce qu'il est vraiment réaliste
d'espérer une réponse de souveraineté
comme vous l'avez qualifié
oui je je je je parlais de souveraineté
parce que lorsque effectivement votre
système juridique est mis en échec ou en
l'occurrence c'est le cas il faut se
rendre compte euh et ben vous avez
nécessairement une question de
souveraineté c'est évident puisque
effectivement ça veut dire que la
question qui renvoie c'est que les gens
dans leur inconsens se disent bah est-ce
que finalement on est on est souverain
chez soi quand je dis on est souverain
la France est souveraine dans ses
territoires alors euh pour moi la
priorité c'est effectivement c'est
l'action diplomatique parce que
effectivement B si vous prenez la Guyane
les frontières sont tellement grandes
que même une action je dirais de
militarisation des frontières quand je
parle de question de souveraineté et que
je la distingue de la question
judiciaire c'est parce que la question
de souveraineté effectivement c'est un
rapport d'état à état mais de de
souveraineté y compris effectivement sur
le plan de la surveillance des
frontières qui basculerait non pas
effectivement dans un droit ordinaire
mais qui considéit effectivement pour le
rend étanche qui ferait appel à des
moyens effectivement de souveraineté pu
qui la souveraineté c'est l'armée voilà
pour vous répondre concrètement ceci dit
il faut être réaliste même si pour un
moment ça peut durer vous pourrez pas
maintenir des frontières étanches
pendant toute l'année pendant c'est
clair vous savez très bien que il faut
bien se rendre compte que nous avons un
environnement qui est qui a une norme
différente qui a
aussi je dirais des objectifs différents
de de la France il faut pas il faut pas
se le cacher euh ils ont d'autres
stratégies
euh moi je mise plutôt sur effectivement
l'action diplomatique euh bon ben je
crois qu'il faut se rendre compte que il
y a que cette action qui
peut oui alors après elle peut
s'accompagner avec des signaux
effectivement
euh de souveraineté alors c'est plus
effectivement l'action en l'occurrence
de présence française aux frontières bon
maintenant elle peut pas durer
éternellement c'est clair parce que N il
faut bien rend compte nous sommes dans
un monde ouvert et quand vous avez des
frontières qui sont effectivement
ouvertes il est bien difficile
effectivement de ça veudrait dire qu'en
l'occurrence que les pays
environnant joueraient le jeu oui oui
oui al on parlait du
Surinam bon qui est un pays qui quand
même pose des problématiques
est-ce que le Brésil mais bon voilà
alors comment AR arriv bon je pense que
on a prouvé qu'effectivement on pouvait
être pouvait être efficace et avoir des
réponses diplomatiques maintenant c'est
savoir la volonté on met le cap c'est ça
c'est ça renvoie une réponse qui n'est
pas judiciaire il faut faut
imaginer que se fonder uniquement sur
unere organisation juridique sur des
réformes oui mais elle n'aura ell
n'auront pas de percussion c'estàd que
ell auront une percussion limitée parce
que nous sommes face effectivement à une
problématique qui qui dépasse celle d'un
d'un
d'un d'un département puisque consid
comme des département c'est l'échelle
d'un pays et qui qui VI même d'un
continent parce qu'on sait très bien que
nous sommes en Amérique du Sud et que le
Surinam aussi ou le Brésil sont des pays
effectivement de
transit on le voit d'ailleurs sur
effectivement d'immigration de de trafic
on sait que par exemple que aujourd'hui
le trafic de Superion est en train de se
se être dérouté vers les Antilles vers
d'autres pour effectivement atteindre
l'Hexagone l'Europe donc on a une
problématique qui est de géopolitique et
de de de de diplomatie en somme quand on
est plus efficace en guyan on expose
davantage les Antilles euh oui
nécessairement vous avez un problème de
base communiquant lorsque vous
effectivement alors après pour pour vous
répondre sur une question
effectivement sur le trafic de stupéfant
vous savez qu'en guyan a été mise en
place dispos de 100 % contrôle bon pour
moi le 100 % contrôle n'existe pas mais
enfin je je je
je je vous dis en fait le dispositif
c'est
quoi et et là on glisse sur quelque
chose qui est à mon sens
juuridiquement
problématique vous avez effectivement
des le préfet euh donc les gens se
présentent à l'aéroport et euh font le
objet d'un contrôle donc par les
policiers et suivant le contrôle on
refuse
l'embarquement c'est concrétisé comment
par un arrêté qui interdit à la personne
5 ou 10 jours sauf que je me suis pensé
sur cette problématique vous avez un
problème vous savez
que en matière dans notre droit dieu
merci la vous avez un principe de
l'égalité des délit des peines connu en
droit pénal
aucune peine effectivement ne ne peuvent
être appliqué si n'est prévu
expresséement par le législateur mais le
Conseil
d'État a indiqué que ce principe
s'applique aux sanctions administratives
or vous avez un dispositif en
guyan qui ne repose sur qu'une
disposition textuelle législateur n'a
jamais prévu effectivement en matière de
débarquement des peines de 5 à 10 jour
et aucune autorité administrative quelle
qu'elle soit en pouvoir réglementaire ne
peut créer des sanctions vous avez un
problème de sanction administrative qui
pose un problème et quand je vous
parlais effectivement de
dérogation je l'ai écrit dans un article
en disant qu'il fallait doter
effectivement le préfet de moyens
effectivement je je comprends il fallait
doter le FR de moyens qui permettent
effectivement de lutter efficacement
c'est d'assoir sur une base juridique
qui soit effectivement incontestable et
qui pas aujourd'hui vous vous navez pas
je suis pas sûr que si demain le Conseil
d'État avait se prononcer qu'il
considérit queeectivement on n pas à
faire des sanctions administratives vous
voyez comme quoi comment
eff en fait on a on a de manière
permanente dans notre m qu'est-ce que
vous observez une tension entre
finalement la règle de droit telle
qu'elle est
construit le code de procédure
pénal et son application sur le terrain
on se rend compte qu'il faut des
réponses et donc on passe à des systèmes
adaptés des combinaisons en fait
qu'est-ce qui se passe en guyan on a
transféré en fait finalement d'une
compétence qui est essentiellement
judiciaire le trafic de SUP relève du
juge judiciaire mais comme le juge
judiciaire n'a pas la capacité et le
procureur de la République actuelle
avait dit moins d'un,5 je ne poursuis
pas je donne des instructions ne pas
poursuivre al ça a été
critiqué moi j'ai un article là-dessus
bon je comprend c'était une question
effectivement de je dirais de de
priorité parce que s'il consacrait tous
les moyens effectivement je comprends à
à la lutte au Superion il pourrait pas
traiter des problème effectivement de de
de de de vol et cetera qui qui qui qui
qui inquiète les gens voilà la
criminalité et cetera donc il a fait ça
mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé c'est
Queen fait on a transféré ça on l'a
administrativé c'est-à-dire que on est
censé servi de la police administrative
qui est unee police je vous rappelle de
prévention en
l'occurrence qui vise à prévenir alors
que la police judiciaire effectivement a
sanctionner à réprimer euh en fait euh
on a transféré euh voilà un problème euh
qui devait au lever du judiciaire avec
finalement un système D qui en fait est
incompréhensible parce que vous n'avez
pas de disposition vraiment expresse qui
prévoit voilà vous voyez les
problématiques merci merci Maître je
vais laisser la parole à notre collègue
Victorin
Lurel merci madame la Présidente
pardonner encore mon retard
j'avoue je suis perplexe en vous
écoutant et j'ai l'habitude de vous lire
de vous entendre euh là je suis un peu
perplexe si on fait des réformes disons
paramétrique vous avez employé le mot
euh il y a pas grand-chose à
espérer puisque on le fait déjà parfois
un peu à la limite du respect des
libertés publique des libertés garanties
euh on donne quelques pouvoirs
supplémentaires au préfet et c'est vrai
que sur la base de l'article 78 je sais
plus quel tiré un ou deux du code de
proc pénal il peut arrêter il peut même
expulser sans même avoir saisi le
tribunal administratif et ça c'est déjà
fait en Guyane mais en Guadeloupe on l'a
vu avec des drames à l'époque il y a eu
des craches d'avion avec des personnes
en situation irrégulière sur le
territoire de la wadelou à ce titre il
peut mettre en rétention et expulser euh
il peut faire des
f avec plus de facilité il peut faire ça
vous dites euh que ça va pas régler le
problème et quand on discute euh au
Parlement qui à l'assemblée qui ici au
au Sénat nous sommes tous un peu
discrets sur ces pouvoirs exorbitants
euh octoyés euh au au au préfet
euh j'avoue que euh lorsqu'on évoque
aussi de Doig du sol et j'ai eu ça avec
d'autres parlementaires Maorais euh on a
compris et on a compris euh même si euh
ça violait quelques grands principes
mais on a compris compte tenu de la
pression migatoire et cela est vrai
peut-être à en Guadeloupe un peu moins s
Martinique mais c'est vrai en Guyane
c'est une évidence et peut-être à
Saint-Martin il y a des problèmes de
contrôle ensuite on a donné quelques
pouvoirs supplémentaires mais c'est
paramétrique euh quelques pouvoirs
supplémentaires à la police à la
gendarmerie de contrôle permanent euh
c'est vrai qu'on a limité chez moi je
sais pas si c'est vrai dans les autres
territoires à quelques route euh
nationale je crois en Guadeloupe ça va
être la RN1 et la RN2 il y a plus d'une
dizaine de routes nationale si on arrête
quelqu'un sur un autre départemental ou
communal ça peut-être casser en droit
processuel enfin en procédure bon ça
peut être cassé
alors et c'est pourtant nécessaire et et
vous dites que le principe d'égalité
c'est vrai vous avez raison pour
s'adapter et bien on a fait et créer ces
exceptions là et vous citez les citoyens
défenseurs à W fouten il y a pas
d'avocat bon on fait pas venir de
Noma on prend je dis pas n'importe qui
il faut qu'il soit agréé et il peut
aller au tribunal et défendre et vous
dites même parfois lorsqu'il s'agit de
juger de crime euh mais oui et donc ces
particularités là existent et vous dites
donc tout ça c'est bien on peut le faire
on a fait chez vous en
Guyane j'étais moi là et on a participé
à ça avec Bertelot et d'autres
parlementaires de donner des pouvoirs
aux officiers de police judiciaire mais
aussi aux agents de police judiciire des
APG euh pour détruire les instruments
euh euh C sans jugement préalable bon
euh tout ça c'est paramétrique et ça ne
fait pas avancer si je veux dire euh une
les causes d'une justice plus efficace
plus efficiente doté de meilleurs moyens
même si euh on fait ce type de
renforcement vous faites 18 propositions
et dans la je crois la 10 vous dites euh
et vous avez parlé de souveraineté vous
dites intégré dans la réforme à venir la
réforme constitutionnelle de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie certains ici pens ça
la création de dispositifs protégeant
l'originalité de chaque territoire ça
qui m'intéresse l'originalité de chaque
territoire et la pluralité
identitaire qui en résulte au sein de la
République comment voyez-vous ça
respecter la pluralité identitaire
est-ce que vous y mettez les langues
est-ce que vous y
mettez la culture je sais pas comment
qualifier ça et en définir son
périmètre la pluralité identitaire au
sein de la République la proposition
10 de fortes adaptations procéder à des
mesures juridiques d'adaptation fortte
pour répondre réalités et problématique
sociétal lié au bassin de j'entends ça
et je comprends ça mais j'aimerais
concrètement comprendre qu'est-ce que
vous avez en tête et qu'est-ce que vous
proposeriez à cette délégation pour
illustrer ces deux proposition si on
laisse le paramétrique mais là qu'est-ce
que en réforme constitutionnelle on
pourrait qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait faire
alors déjà ça serait pas effectivement
dans dans la Constitution enfin oui
pardon oui euh ça serait effectivement
dans son dispositif euh je le voyais
plus effectivement dans dans dans la loi
organique propre à chaque territoire
alors sur sur l'identité qu'est-ce qui
fait l'identité d'un d'un territoire il
y a il y
a je dirais sa culture
euh bon je je je n'invente rien
l'article 72 3 de la constittution dont
son allat prier euh dit la République
reconnaît au sein du peuple français les
populations d'outrer dans un idéal
commun de liberté égalité et fraternité
je ve dire par là qu'on on a bien
conscience que les populations d'autremè
constitue effectivement à l'intérieur du
peuple français à des particularités
linguistiqu de langue
alors vous me disiez qu'en faement
comment je vois cette adaptation bah
déjà c'est de répondre aux
problématiques de chaque parce que je
pense qu'il faut qu'on cesse qu'on qu'on
quitte un prix
qu'on a général de l'outrem pour avoir
un prise qui soit serrié par territoire
alors c'est un défi c'est compliqué a 13
territoires différents 13 populations
enfin il y a 13 territoires puisque tous
les territoires ne sont pas habités mais
pour ceux qui sont habités ils ont des
particularités je prends l'exemple de
wice et Futuna sur lequel j'ai travaillé
et et la Polynésie ils sont radicalement
différent c'est pas la même façon de
voir les choses parce que je pense qu'il
faut se placer au a dans
la la perception qu'à chaque
population de sa vision effectivement de
de Paris mais comment il voit les choses
en l'occurrence il compris le droit
quand je parlais effectivement que le
droit n'a de résonance que si
effectivement
il il inspire la confiance c'est parce
que en
fait je pars du principe que les
réponses juridiques qu'on apporte doit
'adapter à que les G
attendentp jeondis sur m'ave dit sur les
citoyens défense problti que j'ai
soulev vous savez que il y a
desr teritire de la République pas
d'avoc pasavoc
pouroi c'est parce que la
Chancellerie n' pas voulu en tout cas
poura alors même si ça a évolué puisque
ça fait partie de mes
propositions prévu une dotation de frais
de transport pour les avocats de Na
puisque wice et Futuna dépend de la cour
d'appel de alors ça a
entraîner des choses dramatiques parce
que vous avez des citoyens défenseurs
qui ne sont pas agréés pour leurs
compéten sont pas des juriste et vous
imaginez bien que un citoyen défenseur
défondant une affaire correctionnelle
lourde voire criminelle et oui parce que
vous avez il faut
pas VO la face l'institution judiciaire
c'est aussi dérogé c'estàd que bon bah
il est citoyens défenseur il faut faire
avancer les dossiers donc la personne
sera jugé on va pas attendre qu'un
avocat se donc qu'est-ce qui se passait
c'est que le barreau de Na parce que
j'avais vous imaginez bien je m'étais
entretenu avec le bâtonnier de Na pour
voir dans quelle mesure on pouvait
prêter son parce que moi ça ça ça ça je
ve dire ça m'interpelle ça que des gens
ne soient pas défendus par des
professionnels qui sont formés c'est
c'est quand même problématique surtout
en matière pénale et en fait il y avait
ce butoir c'està-dire que la
Chancellerie n'a pas prévu en fait de
dispositif d'accompagnement des avocats
ça veut dire que c'était la change du
barreau vous savez que la seule
collectivité le seul territoire où les
frais de prise en charge sont prévu
c'est la Polynésie française aucun autre
territoire ne reçoit de dotation pour
effectivement les frais de transport des
avocats pour rebondir par
exemple vous avez que ce soit à Na quand
vous avez à
coné l'avocat qui va il est pas pr en
charge
voilà
donc ça pose les problématique alors
pour vous répondre la
solution d'ailleurs c'est l'intérêt que
j'ai fait de créer au sein du Conseil
national de juridique ce groupe
effectivement d'accès au droit c'est
pour justement apporter des réponses
territoire par territoire après
l'audition de chacun des acteurs de
terrain y compris des associations des
gens qui sont sur le terrain parce que
je pense que jusqu'à maintenant nous
avons défini une politique d'accès au
droit en partant du haut en bas
or une politique d'accès au droit qui
soit fiable qui soit convaincante ne
peut qu'émaner effectiv des acteurs de
terrain en
l'occurrence par là que la réponse de
l'accès au droit pour wice et Futuna
pour vous
répondre ne peut pas être la même que en
nelle coné elle ne sera certainement pas
la même en Martinique ou en Guadeloupe
ou encore en guyan la géographie n'est
pas la même et la géographie n'est pas
la même nous sommes dans des bassins de
vie
différents d'ailleurs d'ailleurs on va
on va pousser le le raisonnement un peu
plus
loin pour montrer effectivement comment
effectivement il y a une
différence vous savez que le réseau
bancaire et je suis bien placé pour le
savoir puisque effectivement j'ai des
activités ordinales qui m'amènent
effectivement à à gérer des CARPA euh
vous savez que le réseau bancaire pour
tout l'outremre est considéré comme un
réseau étranger ça veut dire en
l'occurrence que la même banque qui a
implanté sur le territoire
hexagonal sur la BNP Crédit Agricole
chose don sa représentation ultramarine
elle n'a pas les même taux
elle n'a pas la même mode de gestion qui
relève de l'international je peux bien
vous en parler puisqueeffectivement je
vois que les taux d'intérêt ne sont pas
les mêmes queeffectivement par exemple
dans l'exagone autre problématique c'est
que vous avez aussi bah quand vous
arrivez dans l'Hexagone souvent problème
de téléphone vous avez même des
opérateurs qui il vous fait le 30 il il
sont pas adaptés au 594 596 non ce sont
des petits signes qui renvoi à l'idée
que en fait finalement ben l'ultramarin
il est différent il est différent il a
cette perception on le dit pas mais j'ai
pas de langue de bois donc je vous le
dis mais c'est clair c'est c'est
voilà Monsieur le Bâtonnier vous nous
avez dit qu'en
[Musique]
polynésieou l'avocat est transporté oui
enfin oui oui transport est financé je
je voudrais juste vérifier un point
c'est le gouvernement de Polynésie qui a
mis en place ce dispositif non non non
non alors en NouvelleCalédonie en
Polynésie c'est la Chancellerie alors en
Polynésie alors pourquoi pourquoi ce
deux poids de
mesure 118 et ben écoutez pourquoi je me
suis ça la
réponse personne n'a pu m'expliquer
alors je suppose que ça c'était lié au
rapport du président de de la Polynésie
de l'époque et puis du président de la
répu oui c'est ce que le ministre Durel
nous dit c'est c'est la géographie
simplement je veux dire en
Nouvelle-Calédonie le problème se pose
même s'il y a moins d'î il se pose dans
les mêmes termes exactement la même
terme exactement les même terme
d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs je me suis servi de la
proposition enfin de de ce dispositif de
la Polynésie pour l'étendre parce que
j'avais fait c'est pas un dispositif
polynésien c'est un dispositif d'État
c'est un disposi alors vous rappelons
qu'en Polynésie seulement
les oui oui là en fait Polynésie et
Nouvelle-Calédonie vous avez une
particularité pour l'aide
juridictionnelle t ceux qui est pénal
relève de l'État et tout ce qui est
civil relève des gouvernements locaux
j'avais une question sur ça sur entre la
collaboration la coopération entre
l'État et des collectivités mais avant
vous avez raison je tiens à insister sur
ce point-là oui en matière bancaire mais
ça peut relever de stratégies de gestion
interne en filialisant euh mais c'est
vrai que c'est j'allais presque dire
cette étrangeté vous avez la même chose
en matière téléphonique et en matière de
code postal vous êtes vous avez un code
postal qui est différent et on en sait
quelque chose ici la délégation avec
Michel Magra et moi-même quand je
faisais la loi égalité réelle on a eu ça
et d'ailleurs on n'a jamais obtenu la
continuité postale et j'ai même eu une
ministre qui m'a dit je dismie si je
nobtiens pas on l'a pas obtenu c'est
toujours le cas on a quelques
particularités comme ça mais on l' en
matière statistique et douanière euh
nous sommes des territoires
d'exportation mais mais c'est pas une
discrimination au contraire c'est une
c'est un avantage puisque quand vous
exportez vous exportez à tau zé ici et
c'est vous là-bas qui appliquez un tau
de TVA inférieur euh bon euh j'entends
certains économistes dire ça ce sont des
erreurs peut-être je peux même dire des
bêtises donc euh on peut comprendre il y
a des différences sur ce qu'on appelait
à l'époque la 6e directive euh de
l'Europe en matière de TVA bref c'est
vrai que l'adaptation commande tout ça
reste à savoir quelle est son efficacité
moi quand je vous lis c'est vrai qu'il y
a 18 proposition vous avez des
commentaires réguliers et ce qui permet
d'avoir une vision actualisée de ce qui
se fait euh euh chez nous euh j'aimerais
vous interroger sur la l'organisation du
ministère de la Justice comment
voyez-vous le déploiement des moyens du
ministère dans nos territoires
l'organisation des directions
l'administration pénitentiaire qui a une
direction dédiée mais euh pour d'autres
euh ce n'est pas la même chose notamment
la PGJ euh comment ça se passe en terme
de moyens ensuite en terme de moyens ils
sont souvent démunis et pas très dotés
euh moi-même alors président de Région
j'avais décidé de rénover carrément la
cour d'appel et j'ai eu un accord avec
le ministère et notamment l'immobilier
de la justice ça s'est jamais fait
c'était madame tobira qui était là parce
que c'était la dignité de l'État bon les
gens travaillaient dans des contéers et
donc on a voulu moderniser on a même
fait des centres éducatif fermé pour le
compte de l'État comment voyez-vous les
relations alors que c'est du régalien et
tout ça comment voyez-vous donc euh ce
ça relève de une autorité fort égalienne
et l'apport que pourrait avoir dans le
respect des compétences les
collectivités le collègue vient
d'évoquer ce que le gouvernement de
Polynésie a pu faire ou aurait pu faire
comment voyez-vous ça est-ce que on peut
trouverver des coopérations respectant
si je dire les périmètres de chacun les
compétences de chacun le régalien et
d'autres
domaine si permettez comme nous sommes
un peu contraints par le temps ce sont
des sujets qui sont vraiment très très
larges et les collègues souhaiteraient
aussi poser quelques questions je
passerai la parole aux collègues vous
répondrez après et vous pourriez aussi
nous adresser une note vraiment très
complète avec des réponses techniques
très précises sur le sujet donc je vais
laisser la parole à notre collègue tan
Mohamed
SW merci madame la Présidente je je vais
comme d'habitude essayer d'être consis
mais ça va être compliqué tellement le
bâtonnier
l'ingibé a
émis des réflexions pragmatiques et qui
Appell à à la discussion à creuser pour
trouver des des réponses adaptées euh je
voulais partager et et et apprécier tout
ce que vous avez dit euh par rapport
eu à la difficulté d'accès au droit et
certains de nos compatriotes ultramarin
éprouve des difficultés monumentales à
accéder à un auxiliaire de justice pas
qu'X avocats aux notaires
au aux hussiers vous avez parlé de de
l'aide
juridictionnelle alors
que beaucoup de territoires même quand
ils ne sont pas des des îles euh sont
difficiles d'accès parce que ce sont des
archipels ou comme la Guyane c'est pas
moi qui vais vous vous vous apprendre la
la la carte de de la Guyane euh euh
partager aussi le fait que Mayot n'a pas
de cours d'appel de plein exercice
malgré plusieurs demandes malgré euh un
rapport de la commission des Lois du
Sénat ce n'est pas que pour le plaisir
d'avoir une cour d'appel de plein
exercice mais quand la politique pénale
du gouvernement est déclinée au niveau
de la cour d'appel et que vous avez les
chefs de juridiction le procureur
général et le premier président qui sont
à la Réunion
qui ne viennent que deux trois fois à
maot comment voulez-vous que ils aient
une politique pénale adapté à la
situation de de Mayotte et donc je fais
je voulais faire mien vos observations
sur ce ce sujet vous vous n'en avez pas
parlé mais je le rappelle ici c'est un
de vos chevaux de bataille la la en
matière d'immobilier judiciaire la
véuseté un autre maire
l'immobilier vieilli beaucoup plus vite
que euh que ailleurs et nous avons t
tous ces ces ces handicaps et et
j'aimerais soumettre ça sera mon dernier
point un sujet euh à la à votre sagacité
à la sagacité de la de la délégation euh
et et je rebondis sur la question de
notre collègue Philippe Bas sur la
procédure pénale à laquelle vous avez
répondu par euh des considér tion de
souveraineté et de de de coopération
j'étends ma
réflexion sur le la problématique
migratoire la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine ce qui a mis le feu au
poudre actuellement dans la situation de
de Mayotte c'est que en plus de
l'immigration habituelle
euh et bien il y a il y a nous avons des
migrants venant de l'Afrique
continentale l'Afrique des des Grands
Lacs et qui demandent l'asile
politique seulement 5 % d'entre eux ont
obtenu l'asile sur les 700 seulement 40
5 5 et quelques dans la situation
actuelle de Mayot où la moitié de la
population est étrangère où 77 % de la
population vit en dessous ce de pauvreté
nous n'avons même pas d'eau pour la
population
actuelle nous retrouver avec ces
migrants en plus dans la nature migrants
euh que je
ne cherche évidemment pas stigmatisé
mais pour la petite histoire qui n'est
pas si petite que ça parmi ces migrants
on a retrouvé des criminels recherchés
dans leur pays dans le passé on est venu
chercher un génocidaire du
Rwanda qui s'était planqué à Mayot et
qui a été jugé et condamné à perpétuité
dans dans dans l'Hexagone il me semble
donc sans sans
paraphraser l'ancien excellent premier
ministre Mayot qui vit déjà dans une
situation de misère ne peut pas
accueillir en plus toute la misère de
l'océan Indien d'une partie de de de
l'Afrique d'où l'idée et c'est ça que je
voulais soumettre à à votre sagacité
l'idée que j'aimise récemment je ne l'ai
pas je ne l'ai pas inventé
euh l'idée de de de prendre modèle de ce
qui est en train de se faire entre le
Royaume-Uni et le Rwanda euh parce
que la la en plus de toutes les
particularités que je viens de de dire
de
rappeler nous avons un différent euh
avec les Comor
or tous les migrants quasiment qui
viennent à Mayot soit viennent
directement des Comor soit passent par
les Comores et autant vous dire que le
les Comor ne jouent pas le jeu il ils
s'en servent je n'ai pas peur de dire
c'est mot comme arme
migratoire tout simplement et d'où
l'idée de traiter avec un pays tiers
parler de coopération euh euh du du
continent africain pour que les demandes
d'asil pour rejoindre mayat se fassent à
partir de ce de ce
pays je ne vois pas d'autres solutions
viables euh à à long à long terme donc
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
euh de ce
dispositif euh qui pourrait être mis euh
en place en place à Mayot pour soulager
cette le de sa
problématique migratoire inu insensé que
depuis une trentaine d'années nous
n'arrivons pas à résorberite
oui bonjour à tous alors maître lag
jibib vous êtes un témoin privilégié des
travaux passés sur l'évolution
statutaire avez-vous l'impression que
cette nouvelle organisation à faciliter
les échanges avec l'État je vais
anticiper votre réponse pouvez-vous nous
dire sur quel point les nouveaux travaux
menés actuellement par les élus guyanais
doivent s'accentuer pour fluidifier et
simplifier ses
échange
Annique
Pétrus merci madame la Présidente
euh l'accès au doigt est plus plus que
problématique et cré des injustices en
notre mère nous le savons tous je
reviendrai pas
dessus j'aimerais cependant évoquer un
sujet dont on a très peu parlé c'est la
surpopulation carcérale qui s'élève à
123 % en moyenne dans l'ensemble des
territoires ultramarins euh la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme nous le
savons a condamné la France pour
l'indignité de ses prisons en
particulier à cause de trois
établissements situés en notre m le
centre pénitentiaire de ma en Guadeloupe
à croire qu'ils ont pas visité celui de
Baster euh celui de Ducos en Martinique
et la prison de fa nutania en Polynésie
française concernant le territoire de
Saint-Martin lors de débat sur l'état de
la justice dans les outremers que nous
avions pu avoir au Sénat en avril 2023
j'avais pu interroger le ministre
délégué aux outrem de l'époque
Jean-François Carenco sur la
situation du tribunal de proximité de
Saint-Martin j'avais donc plaidé pour
une autonomie de Saint-Martin par
rapport à Baster en présentant bien
entendu des
arguments je reviendrai pas sur ces
arguments là vous conviendrez avec moi
qu'il revient à l'état d'assumer la
continuité territoriale et légalité
devant la justice il n'est donc pas
normal
que l'accès au que les saint-martinoir
et ou tous les
autres territoires ultramarins euh
ne bénéficie
pas comme les Français de l'Hexagone
d'un accès effectif à la justice de leur
pays j'aurai donc deux questions puisque
nous savons tous que ce problème existe
puisque nous en parlons
souvent quelles mesures sont ou seront
prises pour améliorer l'efficacité
l'accessibilité des services judiciaires
dans les territoires d'outremire
notamment en terme de numérisation des
procédures et de déploiement de
personnel judiciaire qualifié et ma
seconde question une demande dans le
cadre du suom avait été formulée par la
collectivité territoriale de
Saint-Martin pour une prison dont les
cours seraient réduits par des espaces
mis à disposition avec le côté
hollandais avez-vous des informations
sur ce sur cette
demande merci chers collègues alors ça
de Omar OL oui merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente je souscris tout à fait tout
ce qui a été dit et je voudrais euh
juste témoigner maître quand vous dites
que le code de procédure pénale va rien
résoudre dans nos difficultés à notre
maire j'étais président du département
et euh j'avais plus de majorité parce
que évidemment
euh j'avais une majorité de 10 et
l'opposition était de 9 donc mon
vice-président a démissionné et j'ai
cherché par tout moyen de le faire
revenir j'avais des difficultés
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait et ben j'ai fait
l'application tout simplement de ce qui
se fait de mieux chez nous c'est-à-dire
la réconciliation nous sommes musulmans
à
Mayot et que on avait une
Cadie qui réglait beaucoup de difficulté
je dirais que on avait même pas besoin
d'aller au
tribunal mais la première chose qu'on
nous a dit si nous voulons bien sûr être
département la première chose qu'il faut
faire il faut supprimer les cadits euh
et donc évidemment on les a supprimer
donc tous les petits conflits qu'on
pouvait régler entre nous
euh sont arrivés au tribunal bien sûr le
tribunal se trouve aujourd'hui avec des
dossiers pas possibles impossible de de
de d'apporter des solutions donc quelle
est votre perception aujourd'hui par
rapport à ce que vous avez dit sur
l'identité euh sur la culture notamment
sur l'article
72 qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui parce que nous voyons que il
n'y a plus de confiance à la justice les
grvistes avantiier euh parmi les cibles
qu'ils ont pris c'est aller fermer la
justice parce qu'ils n'ont plus
confiance à la
justice donc moi la question c'est
d'après vous et tout ce que vous avez
dit que faut-il faire pour
maotte
président juste oui je vous demanderai
d'être très contraint puisque nous avons
une deuxème audition c'est un sujet
passionnant et je vais laisser
rapidement à le Victor une minute 5 ça
prendraas pas une minute dans le la
foulée de ce cas d'itan est-ce que vous
êtes informé des
conditions de admission des personnes en
situation irrégulière par exemple entre
la France et les comors entre la France
Guadeloupe Martini guyan avec le Brésil
avec sainlucie avec la Dominique est-ce
que on peut avoir un bilan de cette
affaire dans quelles conditions
diplomatique juridique financière ça se
passe parce que ça devient si je
comprends bien un
business et pour clore ces questions
maître don vous proposition sur la
pluralité identitaire au sein de la
République euh je pensais
particulièrement au au parallèle que qu'
l'on peut faire entre le droit coutumier
et euh le droit
national alors je vais répondre
à à la première
question de Monsieur le sénateururel
euh alors moi j'ai proposé je crois que
d'ailleurs c'est c'est c'estarcique
puisque comme les états généraux de la
justice dans son rapport limité à de
pages et demi et sans réponse d'ailleurs
concrète pour l'outrem à part des
constats j'ai proposé moi ce qui me
concerne qu'il y a des états généraux de
la justice en outrom
pourquoi parce que alors j'ai même dit
hein comment je je je voyais ces états
généraux c'est la justice elle est rendu
au nom du peuple
français ça veut dire qu'en l'occurrence
c'est pas un débat qui va interroger
uniquement les juges pour moi ces états
généraux devaient effectivement associer
tous les acteurs judiciaires mais
également les acteurs politiques à
commencé par les parlementaires c'est
évident comment voit-on la justice
territoire par territoire qu'est-ce
qu'on peut améliorer qu'est-ce qui
bloque la lisibilité mais c'est ça il
proposit un plan stratégique d'action
territoire territoire oui oui
oui mais sauf que en fait lui sait
rester donc bah le problème c'est que
effectivement ils n'ont pas pris de
sachant spécialist des des territoires
ultr-amarin malgré d'ailleurs la lettre
que le Président de la République m'a
fait et en disant que il demandait
à donc au ministre de la Justice garde
des saut de se rapprocher de moi puce
que j' des propositions concrètes bon ça
pas été fait mais en fait et donc c'est
pour ça que je proposais effectivement
des états généraux de la justice
enreemère à avec effectivement grandeur
nature pour pour réfléchir là-dessus
parce qu'en fait il y a pas une réponse
il y a des réponses et des réponses
adaptées à chaque territoire
euh c'était donc bon pour ça donc
c'était la première réponse la la la
deuxème euh alors euh l'immobilier c'est
vrai qu'effectivement j'avais fait des
propositions parce que aujourd'hui et ça
va répondre à votre
interrogation il y a pas de stratégie
ultrammarine du ministère de la Justice
et je dois vous dire
que la Chancellerie parce que dans les
réunions que j'ai suscité souvent parce
que on je voyais je disais mais où était
le ministère de outromè vous savez que
c'est problématique pour la justice que
le ministère de outromè c'est un
ministre délégué un ministère délégué
sous l'autorité du minist l'intérieur et
comm VO que la justice est l'intérieur
voilà compliqué on me l'a dit je le dis
on dit oui mais bon c'est compliqué on
aurait un ministre effectivement de
plein exercice ça aurait été différent
bon non je les ai mis hein autour table
mais en fait et pour l'immobilier et ben
qu'est-ce qu'on a comme on n pas de
prisme ultramarin pas de direction c'est
que les standards en l'occurrence on le
voit pour l'immobilier qui sont appliqué
sont exactement les mêmes que l'hexagone
alors que finalement c'est très bien que
les les les bâtiments que ce soit
effectivement de justice que ce soit
pénitentiaire vieillisse plus vite en
outreem sur le taux du N pas pas la même
ben oui on n pas on n pas vous voyez en
fait la notion de bassin de vie n'est
pas intégrée le seul ministère qui là
effectivement dans dans dans dans son
raisonnement c'est min des outr m je
vous ai dit en fait quel poids qu'il a
aujourhui B c'est ça il
faut et pour répondre mon sénateur tan
oui pour moi il y a pas de de réponse
uniforme comme j'ai parlé effectivement
l'égalité c'est pas l'uniformité en NRE
mère et c'est je pense qu'il faut des
réponses disruptives qui sort de
l'ordinaire parce que l'objectif c'est
de répondre vraiment au problématiqu
sociétal parce que ce qu'il convient en
fait c'est de quoi te rassurer et de
dire aux gens aux populations que la
République s'incarne dans leur
territoire c'est ça le problème de fond
c'est B en tant que jurist c'est ça qui
m'interpelle moi et attaché à la
République à ses valeurs c'est ça qui
m'pelle le reste si vous voulez bon tu
on a beau faire des discours cours
changer les texes il faut avoir la
pertinence c'est de reconquérir en fait
de donner confiance aux gens en disant
que la République ben c'est pas c'est
pas uniquement un concept il y a un
contenu concret donc pour moi il faut
sortir effectivement donc la votre en
l'occurrence sur laquelle j'ai pas
réfléchi mais bon me somes pas oui tout
à fait n nous avons des débassins de vie
qui nous effectivement contextualise
dans un univers qui tend à à à à à
mettre sous tension notre norme en
l'occurrence donc il faudrait bien
trouver en fait des des scénaris des
scénarios qui sortent de l'ordinaire il
faut composer faut
s'adapter problème sud-américain appelle
des réponses qui soi d'origine ENF qui
qui a une connotation sud-américaine
même si elles sont fr française mais
enfin il faut
euh pour madame la sénatrice sur le
débat statutaire bon
euh moi j'ai toujours dit que les débats
sur l'évolution ou ce que j'ai appeler
l'adaptation en l'occurrence statutaire
puisque pour moi il s'agit en
l'occurrence de modifier des textes un
statut et de rendre compatible avec son
son bassin de vie euh sauf qu'il faut
qu'on fasse attention à une chose j'ai
toujours
dit que une adaptation d'évolution ne
réglera qu'une partie des problèmes
pourquoi et si j'ai tenu à le dire que
les crises sociétales majeures qui sont
produites mettez en en cause des
compétences régaliennes c'est parce que
rien ne sera réglé
l'évolution de l'autonomie moi je je
suis un Ardant partisan de
l'autonomie mais ne réglera pas pour
autant les problèmes effectivement
régaliens qui resteront à l'état ce sont
des compétences qui ne pourront pas être
transférées d'ailleurs pour des raisons
qu'on comprend très bien de liberté
publique de sécurité et cetera que si la
liberté devait effectivement changer
d'un territoire à l'autre en fonction de
conjonure politique ça sera extrêmement
dangereux et moi je je suis totalement
opposé donc parce je suis un défenseur
farouche des libertés mais si je
comprends il y a des problématiques
fortes donc je veux dire que il faut
qu'on reste et puis il faut pas qu'on
oublie aussi qu'est-ce que la France la
France c'est un État unitaire c'est pas
un État fédéral c'est pas un état
régional ah oui oui j'ai écris un
article làessus parce que ah oui oui oui
oui oui tout à fait ben je disais que en
fait bon d's il y a des choses que
bon que je je vois je vois que
efftivement parfois y y a des évolutions
qui amè des réflexions c'est pour ça que
je rque plutôt à la proposition du Sénat
qui pour
moiosition de bon sens qui tient
compteune
réalité accès droit
population carcérale madame la sénatrice
vous parlez de l'accès au droit c'est
bien pour ça que j'ai fait
créer un groupe de travail sur l'accès
au droit d're
au sein du Conseil national de l'aide
juridique c'est bien pour apporter et je
n'ai pas oublié Saint-Martin ou
saint-bartelemi puisque comment je
fonctionne je fonctionne d'ailleurs dans
mes déplacements j'ai moi des retour de
chaque bâtonnier d're en l'occurrence
donc des rapports je sais par exemple la
situation aujourd'hui de Mayotte je
discute je donc chaque jour donc
l'objectif de ce groupe c'est bien
effectivement d'apporter comme vous dit
un une politique d'accès au droit qui
soit effectivement territorialisée pour
l'instant n pas territoriale elle est
laissée si vous voulez à au mains des
des conseils départementaux de l'
juridique pour moi ça suffit pas il faut
effectivement aller à la rencontre des
acteurs c'est comme ça qu'on parle au
droit le droit c'est un élément concret
c'est pas un élément qu'on qu'on énonce
et puis qu'on dit ben le droit existe B
soyez
satisfait le justiciable il attend
effectivement une réalité et pour
l'instant cette réalité n'existe
pas c'est parcours du combattant pour
effectivement accéder à des droit
d'autant plus que je disais c'est dans
un article je critiquais par que le
garde des sous disait que on va régler
le problème la justi avec le 100 %
numérique on peut toujours courir le
100% numérique le numérique il y a une
crise du numérique en d're on a déjà des
difficultés effectiv accéder à des
droits fondamentaux alors vous imaginez
le numérisation sera pas possible
et dernière réponse sur Mayotte
euh chaque collectivité doit amener
une une réponse adaptée bon je ne suis
pas sûr mais ça ça ne gage que moi
que on aurait pu faire autrement que le
statut départemental donc qui
aujourd'hui devra effectivement
reconfigurer honnêtement c'est parce que
il faut on ne peut pas en fait greffer
un un statut indépendamment de
l'identité de la population qui l'anime
ça n'a aucun sens on ver l'assimilation
c'est une notion bien belle mais vous ne
pouvez pas assimiler les gens
jusqu'àignor et d'ailleurs je terminerai
par par par une phrase que je je
rappelle beaucoup effectivement qui qui
résume effectivement toute ma réflexion
d'un grand auteur j'aime beaucoup coup
d'ailleurs avoir le courage d'être
soi-même et d'accepter sa différence et
ce que l'on est réellement et pas ce que
les autres veulent qu' l' reçit c'est
d'Albert Camu c'est toute la réalité de
l'outromur au sein de la République
merci Maître donc avant de clore cette
cette audition nous avons retenu le
constat alarmant que vous faites
paradoxe entre une pauvreté importante
dans les territoires ultramarins et une
vie la vie cher difficulté d'accès au
droit et perte de confiance dans la
justice les crises sociétales majeur qui
mettent en exerg des défaillances dans
l'exercice des compétences régaliennes
de l'État et singulièrement la justice
et le constat qu'il n'y a pas de
stratégis pour la justice en outreem
donc vous proposez d'adapter le doit aux
réalité en créant des juridictions
calibrées qui répondront concrètement
aux réalités des territ
vous avez en ce sens créé un groupe
d'accès au droits outreem au sein du
Conseil national de l'aide juridique et
nous vous en
remercions merci à vous nous sommes
aussi nous acceptons volontiers vos
contributions votre contribution écrite
avec des beaucoup de
technicité dans vos propositions merci
merciad présidenteis le groupe
d'accès fait Crayer
entendra merci
merci bon je vais
vousacompagner